You guys, have you
seen my omelette?
Because I totally thought
that I just had it.
I'm really hungry.
Oh, look, a camera.
Hello.
Welcome to D News,
guys and gals.
Thanks for stopping by.
I'm Trace.
As Colorado sees
the implementation
of legally purchased
marijuana, the drug
is going to be under
increased scrutiny,
and we should all be
paranoid that the days
of pot logic being the
only voice in the room
are burned down.
Pot heads and
friends of pot heads
alike are familiar with the
idea of twilight memory,
or memory loss of long
term, heavy users.
Last year a study by the
proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences,
that took 25 years
to complete, by
the way, determined
long term use of marijuana
will damage the human brain.
In fact, the study gave IQ
tests to children, and then
over time, as some picked up
pot and others didn't, they
continued to test the subjects.
25 years later, those who were
more dependent on cannabis
scored lower and lower on IQ
tests than those who weren't.
The results suggested
that pot, over time,
makes you less intelligent.
They even determined
stopping the use of the drug
didn't return the IQ to normal.
They can't say with 100%
certainty pot smoking makes
you dumber, but this is some
pretty compelling stuff.
Now a new study published
in Schizophrenia Bulletin
tested specifically
the connection
between the drug and
memory impairment.
Using brain scanners,
the researchers
compared normal brains, brains
of those with cannabis use
disorders, as they
called it, and brains
of those with schizophrenia.
What they found was significant.
Those subjects who got blazed
not only had their working
memory impaired over
time, basically, they
were more forgetful and had
trouble remembering things,
but their physical brain
structures changed.
The stereotype of
the forgetful stoner
doesn't end when they come
down, but instead, their brain
is physically altered,
perhaps permanently.
More study is needed to
know how this happens,
and what it's doing exactly.
Unfortunately, as pot has
been illegal for so long,
there aren't a good deal of
long term studies looking
at its effect on
human physiology.
Now that the legalization
wave has started,
yes, I assume it's a wave, like
the domino effect, only funner,
scientists will have more open
access to admitted smokers.
The tetrahrydrocannabinol,
or THC,
that gets marijuana
users high, has also
been linked to psychosis.
Thus, the
schizophrenia subjects.
But more research is
needed there, too.
I mean, the casual user hasn't
really been studied at all.
Science.
Get on it.
Regardless, the idea
that pot is somehow
magically without a single
negative aspect or effect
is pretty much completely bunk.
There are plenty of negatives
to ingesting chemicals, whatever
they may be, especially
in large quantities.
As the saying goes,
everything in moderation.
How do you feel
about legalization?
Is it going to make for
better weed, or worse?
Tell us your thoughts
right down there,
and if you want to watch
some other videos we've
done on marijuana
and its effects
on the body and the brain,
you can click over there.
And be sure you subscribe
for more D News.